good afternoon it's a pleasure to speak
to you today about genetic counseling
post the SCOTUS gene patent decision
fast forward so those of you who are
familiar with cancer genetics you know
that the last year has been quite
chockful for the field of cancer genetic
counseling and testing and much of this
started in May of 2013 when Angelina
Angelina Jolie wrote an editorial in the
New York Times stating that she carried
a brca1 mutation and had in fact had a
preventative bilateral mastectomy and we
know that referrals to centers like Yale
cancer genetic counseling increased by
about seventy percent that day and
although they've dipped back down
they've never quite reached the normal
level and so that brings me to brca1 and
2 for those of you who don't work in
this field every day we're going to do a
quick review brca1 not pronounce Braca 1
by the way stands for breast cancer one
and we know that it was cloned in 1994
and that we all carry two copies of
brca1 one on the chromosome 17 inherited
maternally and the other on chromosome
17 inherited maternally we know that
women who inherit a mutation in brca1
have an increased rate of developing
breast and ovarian cancer and that men
who carry a mutation have an increased
risk of developing prostate cancer brca2
is a completely different gene on a
completely different chromosome but it's
also associated with a high risk of both
breast and ovarian cancer in women who
carry a mutation in this gene and an
increased rate of prostate cancer in men
and we're beginning to learn now the
prostate cancer particularly with brca2
carriers tends to be earlier
set prostate cancer and unfortunately
it's often aggressive we know that
pancreatic cancer is also increased in
brca1 and 2 carriers but particularly
with brca2 and it's found in men and
women and that the risk of male breast
cancer is also highest in male erca two
carriers there are mutations and brca2
found all over the world in every ethnic
background no ethnic background is
exempt and they're found throughout
brca1 and 2 in terms of location within
the genes three of those mutations i
should say are found again and again and
again in people of Ashkenazi Jewish
ancestry or in fact I would even say
Jewish ancestry because we see them in
Jews who are not of Eastern European
descent as well and the carrier wait
there is one and 43 for people who carry
a mutation we know that the four women
who carry a brca1 mutation that the
lifetime risk of breast cancer is
somewhere between 55 and eighty-five
percent and you can see that the
lifetime rests with brca2 are similar
compare that to the general population
risk which is eleven to thirteen percent
and you can see that those are greatly
elevated risks we also know that because
these women carry a BRCA mutation in
every cell of their bodies but they have
an increased risk to develop a second
breast primary and so what this means if
a BRCA carrier develops in breast cancer
it's detected in an early stage they
have that cancer removed they have
chemotherapy or radiation that cancer is
gone they still carry a copy of that
mutation in every single cell of both
breasts hence their risk to develop a
second or even a third breast primary as
higher than it is for the average breast
cancer survivor we also know that cancer
of the ovary is increased and BRCA
carriers so for the general population
there's
one to two percent risk of ovarian
cancer you can see that that's markedly
increased for brca1 and 2 from male
breast cancer particularly with brca2
high risks of breast cancer between five
and ten percent lifetime risk much much
higher than the general population risk
of less than one percent prostate
cancers increased brca1 and 2 and
pancreatic cancer particularly with
brca2 increased four to eight percent
lifetime risks so what are the options
for someone who carries a mutation in
one of these genes there are several
options surveillance so in this
population we're not going to begin
surveillance at age 40 we're going to
begin surveillance as soon as we know
about the mutation if the patient is
aged 25 or older or ten years before the
earliest onset of breast cancer in the
family beginning at about age 18 the
surveillance is going to be more
aggressive it's going to include
mammograms and breast MRIs at 6-month
intervals it's going to include exams by
a breast specialist and we know that the
surveillance will also not only be
earlier surveillance it would be more
aggressive surveillance chemoprevention
not to be confused with chemotherapy is
a medication that a healthy patient can
take who carries a mutation before they
ever develop breast cancer to reduce
their risk of getting the disease so
medications like tamoxifen some
aromatase inhibitors can be used in this
way and we believe can reduce the risk
in BRCA carriers immensely we have a
little data but the data we do have
suggest it greatly reduces their wrists
the third option is prophylactic surgery
and again this has gotten a lot of press
in the last year we do know that
bilateral prophylactic mastectomy is an
effective option for BRCA carriers it's
not the option chosen by all carriers
and it's fine
means the only option it's one of the
options and it does reduce the risk of
future breast cancer greatly by more
than ninety-five percent in terms of the
options for ovarian cancer risk
management they may look the same but
they're quite different they begin with
surveillance and currently we have the
blood tests ca125 and transvaginal
ultrasound unfortunately this
surveillance has not been shown to
detect ovarian cancer in an earlier more
treatable stage so that's not very good
surveillance the second option is chemo
prevention which in this case includes
birth control pills we know that birth
control pills can reduce the risk of
ovarian cancer by as much as 60 percent
perhaps even more in BRCA carriers if it
increases the risk of breast cancer at
all it increases it minimally the third
option is prophylactic surgery and the
surgery of choice right now is removal
of ovaries and fallopian tubes and we
know that having that surgery once the
pathology comes back clean reduces the
risk of ovarian cancer substantially
again by more than ninety percent so I'd
like to talk now a little bit about my
entry into the entire BRCA patent debate
and I actually was recruited to come to
Yale to start the cancer genetic
counseling program in September of 1995
and interestingly there was no clinical
brca1 to testing available at that time
so we were meeting with patients taking
their family trees and looking to see if
the cancer in the family looked for
reddit airy and if so based on the
pattern and the family giving the
patient an estimate of the chance that
he or she carried a mutation and so
believe it or not it's really not that
long ago people were making decisions
about whether or not to have a
preventative surgery not based on
whether or not they carry the mutation
because we didn't know but based on what
their risks were
based on the pattern and the family that
was September so soon after my arrival
at Yale December of 1995 testing became
available and there was huge media
coverage referrals poured and and we
began doing testing and the exciting
thing about the testing is that all of
these patients who'd been making
educated guesses were now able to have a
blood test and learn if they carried a
mutation in brca1 and we were doing the
testing at the DNA diagnostics
laboratory at Yale and with antiquated
equipment it cost sixteen hundred
dollars and then a few short years later
the director of the laboratory received
a cease and desist letter to stop all
testing that Muriel genetics had patents
on these genes that they had now decided
to enforce and that's when things
changed so even though as you can see
the cost per base of DNA sequencing and
synthesis has plummeted over the years
with the start date here shown at about
nineteen eighty eight the cost of
testing overnight roads from sixteen
hundred dollars to twenty four hundred
dollars because we've all had to send
our testing to myriad genetics and Mary
Ann began advertising the testing and
these are excuse me some of their
advertisements the only thing worse than
hearing you have cancer is hearing it
twice and there was a lot of criticism
of Myriad's ads and where they put the
ads how they placed the ads this was not
regulated by the FDA or the FTC and so
they didn't have control of the content
to make sure that the pros and the cons
were being presented and they also
launched some very smooth television
campaigns that played in some wealthy
cities across the country and in my
opinion if you watched one of these
advertisements
you would be convinced that you needed
BRCA testing if your neighbor had breast
cancer and so a lot of women were scared
by this campaign and had genetic testing
and what we saw is that insurance
companies were being inundated with
inappropriate requests for the testing
and so not surprisingly what they began
doing is clamping down clamping down on
crew could get the testing the criteria
became very strict and in fact even
today with Medicare if a patient is over
65 and has Medicare they cannot have
brca1 and 2 testing until they
themselves have developed the BRCA
related cancer and so even for someone
who has a known mutation in a first
degree relative they will not qualify
for testing and so with all of the
changes surrounding in my opinion the
patent and the monopoly that was created
by myriad genetics I wrote a paper with
art Kaplan from the University of
Pennsylvania called direct to confusion
lessons learned from marketing BRCA
testing and this article having a
co-author like art Kaplan landed on the
cover of the American Journal of
bioethics and suddenly there was a lot
of attention and a lot of focus on what
it meant to have a patent on a gene and
what that was doing to the field to the
cost of testing and also to patient care
and so soon after just a few years later
we learned that there was a lawsuit
against myriad genetics and then the US
Patent Office and that the ACLU was
behind this and so this lawsuit was
filed may12 2009 and it worked its way
up through the court system and went to
the Supreme Court on April fifteenth
2013
and as many of you know jun 13 we
received the unanimous verdict against
the patenting of genomic DNA and so
things changed and I had been asked
ahead of time what my predictions were
that if patents were abolished by the
Supreme Court how did the field change
and I said that within three months of
the verdict I thought we would have
faster better cheaper testing and I was
definitely wrong because we had that
within five hours of the verdict and I
love this advertisement ding dong in a
unanimous decision the US Supreme Court
rules that gene patents are invalid
finally opening the door for more
competition more complete and
cost-effective testing and so this is
just a short cable of some of the other
laboratories offering BRCA testing and
I'd like to point out a few things here
you can see the discrepancy in price and
so some laboratories myriad specifically
still to this day charging more than
four thousand dollars per patient for
BRCA 2 1 and 2 testing and other
laboratories while all other
laboratories charging at least fifty
percent of that cost some even less and
I should also say that all other labs
are offering something called Bart
testing as part of their brca1 and 2
testing package so everyone who gets
brca1 and 2 testing gets large deletion
and rearrangement testing but myriad I
believe is the only laboratory still
charging extra for that and there are
still some insurance companies that will
not cover Bart testing the other
difference that I think is important to
know is that the data sharing piece so
you can see that all of the other
laboratories currently offering brca1
and 2 testing are sharing their data and
public databases
and myriad genetics is none and so that
is a complicated and very controversial
topic and there are now entire clinical
groups who will only use laboratories
that share their data publicly and
there's some insurers or moving in that
direction that they are not going to pay
for any genetic testing from a
laboratory that won't share their data
publicly because what happens of course
is that if data are hoarded in private
databases that benefits the company it
doesn't benefit patients it doesn't
benefit clinicians trying to interpret
those test results and it doesn't
benefit clinical research and I should
know that it's interesting to think that
many of our tax dollars are paying for
genetic testing when you think about
publicly funded insurance companies and
so it does seem like the at least the
data should go back into a public
database and so when other companies
began offering testing myriad one by one
was suing them and that has not changed
there was another announcement about
that this week and I should point out
that before the change in testing
policies which I'm going to talk to you
about my group published a series of
paper papers and the third was just
published on errors and delivery of
cancer genetic services and basically
what this shows is that although brca1
and 2 testing may seem like a simple
test to order a simple test to interpret
that what we found is that unfortunately
that's not true that many people are
ordering the wrong testing which at best
is costing patients and insurance
companies thousands and thousands of
dollars and tests that don't need to be
order at worst patients aren't having
the right test so just to give you
something
Apple's patients with a test that would
only be detected by deletion duplication
testing are having full sequencing and
holding they're told they're negative
and so we have some patients who haven't
had their ovaries removed who've gone on
to develop ovarian cancer other side of
the coin the interpretation is quite
complicated so some patients who
actually carry a variant of uncertain
significance which turns out to be a
polymorphism have been told that they
carry a mutation and believe it or not
we have patients who've had a bilateral
prophylactic mastectomy just like
angelina jolie did to later learn that
in fact they didn't carry a real
mutation we have other patients who've
had either hysterectomies or affected
means or vote for the same reason later
learning that they didn't need surgery
we've also had patients who have
completely different syndromes so two
sisters with ovarian cancer who are BRCA
negative and are told that it was
lightning striking twice when actually
when you expanded the history to four
generations it was Lynch syndrome and it
was clear that it was Lynch syndrome and
other family members died because the
wrong diagnosis was made so that was in
the world of brca1 and 2 testing this is
the world in which we now live now that
the market has opened up every other
laboratory is offering panel testing
which has huge benefits and a lot of
potential and one thing I'd like to
point out to you is that on this list is
Paul B to a gene that has recently
received a lot of press is being a new
gene brca2 point out that it's not a new
game we've known about it for years and
it's on many of these panels but I want
you to think for a moment if people were
confusing brca1 and 2 testing and they
can't order or interpret that accurately
what do you think is going to happen now
that we're offering these huge panels of
gene tests and that most of these games
we have much less information about then
we had about brca1 and 2 they're going
to be variants events
significance in these jeans and even for
people who really carry a mutation the
clinical recommendations about how to
follow those patients and are they
candidates for surveillance if so how
often what type how about chemo
prevention how about prophylactic
surgery it's getting much more
complicated so I think we can expect
that error rate unfortunately to go up
we know that some insurers cigna being
the first on a national level are now
actually requiring genetic counseling by
a certified provider before they will
consider the cost of some genetic tests
and this may be the wave of the future
that we're looking at a system that's
saying WOW clinicians unfortunately are
being encouraged by some of these
genetic testing companies to hang up a
shingle and be their own genetic
counselors the error rate is so high the
amount of money wasted of our healthcare
dollars is so high and then the results
are misinterpreted this doesn't make
sense we need to make sure that we're
ordering the right test and interpreting
it correctly not only for the patient in
front of you but for all of their family
members think of the long-term
ramifications for dozens sometimes
hundreds of family members and so the
last year has been really impactful for
the field of cancer genetic counseling
now that with the Angelina affect many
people know about genetic testing and
it's really brought it from an academic
clinical setting to the level of the
coffee shop that you can talk to people
in a coffee shop and say if you heard of
genetic testing and they have and so
what we're going to see moving forward
people being less afraid of genetic
testing more interested in genetic
testing which brings us to the next
issue which is direct-to-consumer
testing and I'm going to be using
23andme as an example today but there
are other companies that either exist
now or are in start-up mode who are
offering direct to consumer
testing and of course what this means is
that you can order a test a kit online
it's sent to the consumer in the mail
they can usually spit in a tube send it
back and have genetic testing performed
and so 23andme has had a lot of press
over the last few years some good some
bad for their vtc plans and last
Thanksgiving the FDA ruined your plans
to buy 23 in these tests as a Christmas
present by shutting them down in terms
of offering results for the genetic
testing they could still offer ancestry
in raw genetic data and so for ninety
nine dollars you can still get your
ancestry data in your rah genetic data
but no interpretation and so 23andme has
been grounded but i'd like to say
they're temporarily grounded and they
and other direct-to-consumer testing
companies have not gone away they're
just halted temporarily and what we know
is that some of these companies are
going to get it right they're going to
offer good testing at low prices with
accurate reports that consumers can
understand and it's going to be an
option for the future and there will be
pros and cons but one of them will get
it right and so with that I'd like to
invite you to type in your questions
about genetic counseling post scotus
gene patent decision and this incredible
last year of fast forward development in
the field
okay so we now have a question and this
comes from nicole thompson at howard
university cancer center do you think we
will eventually do away with single gene
or single syndrome testing and progress
toward panels for all high-risk
hereditary cancer patients and Nicole I
think there are pros and cons and I'm
sure you've seen them as well but i
think that the one-stop shopping we're
seeing with some testing companies
saying that they're going to go away
from single gene testing and only offer
panels it's probably not the answer of
course in a family with a known mutation
let's say a family with a reputation I
don't think it's really necessary in
most cases to offer a full pound it's
going to be more expensive we're going
to have variants of uncertain
significance that Papa I also think from
our experience at Yale over the last
year we were looking at panel testing
compared to single gene testing for
people who were presenting with what
looked like hereditary breast and
ovarian cancer syndrome and what we
found is that we had a lot of variants
of uncertain significance but very few
true mutations and jeans other than
brca1 or 2 when there wasn't a family
history that screamed leaf rimini or
that screamed you know hereditary
gastric cancer and breast cancer so I
think the jury is an out I don't think
that we should flip the switch and say
we're only going to do panel testing I
think we need to look at some data and
examine the costs as well as the pros
and the cons because if we're only
uncovering more variants of uncertain
significance we may be doing more harm
than good
you
okay well thank you very much for your
attention